claude charest et sa conjointe n'ont pas
le coeur à remplir des boîtes un avis
d'éviction les force à quitter leur nid
douillet enfin après 23 heures dans un
logement qu'on a mis à notre goût qu'on
a décoré qu'on a même participé à
rénover avec l'ancien propriétaire
c'était si difficile de quitter
l'entreprise optiplex qui a acheté
l'immeuble de vie logement du quartier
limoilou entreprend des travaux majeurs
pour rénover est subdivisé le bâtiment
le couple a contesté un premier avis
pour rénovations majeures en 2019
mais en décembre dernier il a reçu un
avis légal d'éviction les locataires
sont non seulement forcés de quitter
leur appartement mais aussi le quartier
on déménage de cette terre complètement
en idf signer pour s'en aller j c'est un
phénomène low key qui est en forte
augmentation à québec et
particulièrement dans les quartiers
centraux de la capitale selon le bail un
organisme des dons locataires on a
quelque chose comme cette fois plus
d'appels cette année qu'on en avait lieu
2 1 pour ce sujet lors les rénovations
et les élections pas grandi mais les
reprises de logement des tactiques selon
lui pour augmenter de façon importante
le prix des loyers
les propriétaires ont refusé notre
demande d'entrevue mais affirme que ces
travaux sont essentiels la corporation
des propriétaires immobiliers elle
rappelle que les propriétaires doivent
assurer la rentabilité d'un parc
immobilier vieillissant et le seul moyen
c'est de pouvoir avec les logements par
des moyens tout à fait légaux ou
illégaux dans certains cas on ne voit
pas s'être louer le logement du prix du
mans est possible question la ministre
des affaires municipales et de
l'habitation se dit sensible aux sujets
sont attachés ajoutent par courriel que
des travaux sont d'ailleurs en cours au
ministère pour renverser le fardeau de
la preuve en cas d'éviction pour que ce
soit aux propriétaires de justifier ces
travaux
claude charest est résigné un logement
neuf l'attend à lévis avec un loyer est
trois fois plus cher que celui qu'ils
paient ici ici quelques arpents tirs est
au canada québec